mı
geldi canakkalekoleji dünya resmin
olduğu Bugün sizlerle ilgili
düşüncelerimi paylaşmak istiyorum
Öncelikle
o özellik ve şunu söylemek istiyorum
Eğer isimde bir yanlışlık oldu diye ben
de şey yaptım öncelikle şunu söylemek
istiyorum yani Öyle bir imkan olsa
Türkiye'deki bütün okulların
ve bütün öğretmenler odasına Atatürk'ü
şu cümlesini yazar büyük harflerle Hasan
bu
eğitimde reform Her şeyden önce
öğretmenin havasında başlar Evet
öğretmeni çok güzel İyi ki çok güzel
anlatan bir cümle cümleden Ben de
anlıyorum Şu anlıyorum hangi eğitim
sistemini uygularsak uygulayalım herkese
farklı yaparsak yapalım hangi müfredatı
hangi kazanımı öğretirsen öğrenelim
önceliğiniz öğretmen öğretmenim Fikri
bir öğretmenin öğrenciyi yaklaşımını
öğretmenin yaptıkları ve öğretmeni
uyguladıkları
o örenme çok küçük
O yüzden ayarlarına gitti doğru bir
öğretmen
dersini çok az olan bir öğrenci ile ama
öğrencide ki parıltıları yakalayıp
aparatlar üzerine gidip olup anlatabilir
Var mısın en önemli noktası
bu nesneyi veya bir Fizik öğretmeni
düşün
ve her şişerken tahliye çizgi olacak
şekilde hayal edin az öncekiler dersi
Belki çok az bile gidiyorlar bu
şekillerden etkilenerek ben o şekilde
severek var resme ilgili verebilirler ve
hayatlarının devamında o resimle ilgili
çalışmalarını verecek değiştirebilirler
Hatta yarıdan Esra olanlar bir
içilebilir alalım
ve İspanyolca konuşan bir matematik
öğretmeni düşün
ki doğdun öğretmendi sırasında varsa
aslında razı olsun
İsmail tutoğlu cümleler öğrencinin
etkileyebilir o yabancı dile ilgisini
arttırabilir yerde öğrenciler belki
İspanyolca ara Görüntülü konuşabilir
bu ve Evet çalmasını bilen bir edebiyat
öğretmeni hayalet
Allah
rahmetini getirsin Ben odası olmak
isterdim
Ne haber göndersin yanında o klarnetin
güzel karısı Belki o öğrenciler arasında
hoşlanabilir ler ve bu öğrenciler
arasında güvenlik bilgi verebilirler
ekleyebilirler
Hatta Merve ki yaşamlarında güvenlik
sanatçıları ve çıktığında
arttırabiliriz Örneğin son dönemlerde en
çok karşımıza çıkabilen oyun bilgisayar
oyunu tasarlayan bilgisayar oyunu üreten
bir tarih öğretmeni düşün bütün
öğrencilere iyi olan ne
bir tarif dersin yanında bilgisayarla
ilgili acaba öğretmenimiz bugün neler
anlatacak diye dikkat çocuklar onu
serilir onu binler
O benim gibi örneklerimiz arttırabiliriz
sen ismi kimya öğretmeninin hayali bütün
dünyayı Gezmiş bir coğrafya öğretmenine
Yani işin aslı İşin özü
öğretmendir bir öğretmen
Sen kendini ne kadar çok ayrılırsan
öğrencilerle bu kadar güzel bir ışık ol
bu işin özü Bence bu
abone ol Evet şimdi Tabii ki
Selam
bugün gelmeden Tabii ki bizim evladımız
Hayaller hayallerin ötesinde hayaller ve
hayallerin ötesinde ulaşabilmemiz için
bir çok iyiydi almamız lazım
çok iyi
biz bunları bu eğitimleri bal kitap
okuyarak gerçekleştirdiğimiz lazım ve
üretime çok çok önem vermem sana
Evet şimdi Tabii ki
biz bunları Aslında bizim Öğretmenler
olarak başlayabiliriz sonra
öğrencilerimize bir şey olmamız
gerekiyor şimdi bakalım ne kadarmış
olabilmiş iz onu göstereceğim size
en iyi her şeyi beni sitesinden aldım
bir grafik matematik testi soruları
boş bırakılmaya yüzeylerin doğru
cevaplama yüzdeleri Türkiye geneli Tabii
ki mavi ile gördüğümüz gözün bilmiyorum
ama boş bırakılmaya yüzleri inanılmaz
fazla da aynı şekilde her alanında daha
fen bilimlerinde de Allah bizi kimya
biyoloji alanlarında da boşluklar
inanılmaz fazla
ve bu ÖSYM
kendi sesinden dediğim gibi aldın bizi
Görüldü mü ama bunu Ama bunu bir saat ve
hiç sınavlarında da bu iyisiydi kurucu
üyesi olmamıza rağmen
oy
rağmen
maalesef
eğitim sistemi Öğretmen ve öğrenci
üçgeninde
ama bazı akşamlar oldu aşkım
Ya bırak sonuçları bugün Atatürk nasıl
tespit etmiştir
abone ol
ve Eskişehir'de eğitim üzerine yaptığı
bir toplantıda
söylediği cümleler izah ettim
de bundan önce her biri için babanın bir
programı vardı
dedi gidin eğitimde çeşitli programların
uygulanması öğretmeni öğretmeni berbat
hale getirdi Efendiler
hükümetlere gelen her bakan hey kendine
göre bir program yapıyor ve onu
uygulanıyor bir müddet sonra başka bir
bakan geliyor O da beğeniyor başka bir
program uygulanıyor Bu ne ya afet bundan
sonra izlenecek yol her an değişmeyen
birini çizgisi olan eğitim dir
bu vuran Yıllar yıllar önce
atatürk'ümüzün tespiti beşli ki bu
çizgiye ulaşabilmiş Biz biz bu çizginin
neresindeyiz son Suna
sevabımız Tabii ki birtakım
değişikliklerle karşımıza çıkıyor ama
1938 2021 yılları arası
13 yıl cevizine 58 Milli Eğitim Bakanı
değişir
yani 10 gibi ayda bir değişen eğitim
bakarız
ve en uzun bir eğitim bakanımıza Hasan
Âli Yücel sekiz yıla
O biraz sanayi üzerinden eğitime bu
ülkeye katkıları ayrı bir konuşma metni
bu
değişikler değişiklikler bizim nereden
nereye getirir
1974 yılında özlemek vurulmuş herkesi
sıra sistemine geçmişiz bundan önce
ne oldu bir sınavları bizi bitirme
sınavlarıyla noktaya gelmişiz 76-80
yılları arasında tek o toplu
Üniversiteye giriş sınavı ile
öğrencilerimiz almışız ücreti bu 81
yılında çift olumlu iki oturumda sınav
sistemine geçmişiz Tabii ki oturup
değişimleri hep müfredatta kazanılabilir
değişikliklere sebep oluyor isimler
devamlı değişiyor Tabiki 99 yılında
tekrar pek oturdu üniversite sınavına
geçirmiş
aradan Çok geçmeden 2006 Yıldız daha
tekrar tekrar çift oturumlu sınavlara
geçirmiş 2017 yılında da para 2012
yılında
4646 42 Eğitim sistemimizin değiştirmiş
iz 2016 yılında da
yine isimlerle beraber
değişiklikler karşında
bu değişiklikler ne değişiklikler bizim
açımızdan nasıl önemli bilmem
bu üretim Esad'a ekonomiye tarıma
kaliteli birey yetiştirme bizim maalesef
engelliyor
Eğer birinde söz sahibi olmak
bu teknoloji üretmek
teknoloji ihraç etmek bilir üretmek ağır
sanayi ürünleri üretmek ihraç etmek
maalesef değişen programlarla zorlaşıyor
abone ol
her Türk gencine hızla verildiğinde iyi
eğitimler aldığında neler
yapabileceklerini çok önceden defalarca
kanıtladı
arkalarında durulduğunda defalarca
Atatürk'ün eğitim almaları için bir
kıvılcım olarak gönderdiği Türk gençleri
bakın yılda bir alev olarak nasıldır
2923 yılında Vecihi Hürkuş la beraber
başlayan havacılık faaliyetleri
3928 yılında Kayseri'de uçak fabrikası
kullanarak daha
119 36 yılında Nuri Demir var özel bir
teşebbüsle Sivas'ta bir uçak fabrikası
bul
Ama bu şaka videosu kurdu ve uçaklar ve
etmeye başlar
Bu faaliyetlerin havacılık faaliyetleri
devamı olarak da
1941 yılında başta söylediğim Hasan Âli
Yücel'in de büyük katkılarıyla
Etimesgut Ankara'da bir uçak fabrikası
bu
313 mühendis 220 teknisyenle başlayan bu
fabrikat beş sene sonra
1946'da
957 çalışıyorlar
bu ve o havlu dantel projesi
gerçekleştirdi bu hayat verir
Ha bu arada geçen projeler arasında
Bu işlem uçakları
bilinirler nakliye uçakları
ambulans uçakları
bu iyidir uçakları zamanı görüntü
ambulans canlı Hatta iki kişilik çift
motorlu bir yolcu uçağı da tasarlandı
maalesef
vuruş olarak kaldı hayata geçirdi
Bu ne bu fabrika bu saldırıyla
1949 yılında Hayır havacılık fuarında
gidiyor Türk'e şeyle beraber
uçaklarını sergiliyor ve galiba kadar Bu
gördüğünüz ambulans uçağına hep giriyor
ve ambulans kucağına Türkiye tarihinde
ilk kez
1951 yılında uçuş izni alarak lan beni
arkaya ilk kez ihraç ediyor yıl 1951
bu Türkiye'nin Azimli ve kararlı
çalışmasıyla öne çıkan sonuç Çünkü
Türkiye'nin
neler başarabileceği
O biraz yapabileceği büyük bir
potansiyelin olduğu ortada muhtaç
olduğun Kudret damarlarındaki Asil kanda
mevcuttur
bu ve bulacaklar ihraç edildikten sonra
İsveç ve Danimarka hükümetleri hep
tekrar talepte bulundu var ama biz bu
talebe karşılık veremedik veremediğimiz
gibi bu ne dediğimiz gibi tabi kadarına
İlerleyen süreçlerde bir
emperyalizmi
ortasında buldu kendiniz işaretlenir
Bu harika Türk gençleri aynı Türk
gençliği 1961 yılında
Ben 23 Türk gencinin bir araya
gelmesiyle
129 gün gibi kısa bir süre içerisinde
abone ol
229 gün gibi kısa bir süre içerisinde 2
adet tamamı yerli
otomobil yaptı bir Aralık olabilir
Bu motoru
kabartay ağacı
tekerlekler geldi elektrik sistemleri
geldi tamamen yani her şeyiyle bir
mucize gecesini gündüzüne kadar çalışan
Türk mühendisleri
bu eserlerim
o dönemlerde Yani aynı dönemde dediğimde
beş sene sonra
1966 yılında
o
ilk otomobil mi Tamam İbrahim olduğu
nokta dünyada en çok ihraç o doğru ihraç
eden eşi tür bizim oturabilir Sizlerde
de Eskişehir'de üzerine Biz bunu bebekli
özelliği birebir Birebir ticari
emperyalizmi
ortasında kendimizi
her
Türk gencinin her zaman arkasında
durulduğunda
neler yapabilecekleri tekrar tekrar
ortak
ama sözlerime
sözlerimi bitirmeden önce 1930 yılında
Sen ne yapıyorsun Atatürk'ün ve müziği
hali iyi ile beraber yazdıkları Ben bir
ihtiyaç çocuğu yok Hilmi'nin küçük bir
bölümüne girmek istiyorum Bu filmlerde
derseniz bu film çekilmeye başlandı
havada Türk'ün ömrü Vefa etmedi
ben size oynamak ve saatleri ama
bildiğimiz gibi öbür faizi ve çekilemedi
bu Süper Lig uzun bitirmek istiyorum bir
zaman gelir Beni unutmak veya unutturmak
isteyen gayretler belirebilir
fikirlerimi inkâr edenler
hücrelerinde kusur arayanlar çıkabilir
ve hatta Bunlar benim yakından bildiğim
ve inandıklarım arasından bile olabilir
Ama çok merak ettiğiniz Sorular o kadar
özgü ve kuvvetlidir gibi fikirler bitter
Bu sırada döner dolaşır bir yine gelir
peyzi neticeleri harfleri doldu ve
dinlediğiniz için teşekkürler yorum at